hello and welcome today shiki-san show
in this video we'll look at the fourth
dimension to medicine chrono therapy so
yes this video will be all about chrono
therapy and how time can play a really
important aspect to medicine so firstly
we'll talk about what it is then I'll
give some examples of why we know it
might be effective and then I'll discuss
why the current researchers and some
issues with the application of chrono
therapy in the future so chrony therapy
goes hand in hand with circadian rhythm
and so I recently did affiliate while I
looked at how defects and the circadian
rhythm can cause disease but this video
will look at the opposite and when I
kept how knowledge of the circadian
clock can help us prevent disease and
despite the lack of use I recently
rewatched that video and it's actually
quite good
so I recommend watching it anyway thanks
for this video so this video is about
chrony therapy and say quinna therapy is
the treatment of an illness or a
disorder by administering a drug at a
certain time of the day and the logic
behind this is because it coincides with
the natural rhythms or the circadian
rhythms are cycles that goes on in our
biology so what is the circadian rhythm
so circadian rhythms are biological
processes that occur with about 24-hour
periods and say on this clock of health
there are certain events that happen
throughout the day because they are
regulated by the circadian clock and so
I have a video on that as well which
would go into more detail the point is
is that different things happen at
different times of the day and there's a
very complicated and interesting biology
that underpins that and so this video
we'll look at chromotherapy
or the field of chromo pharmacology
which is basically it analyzes how the
metabolism of drugs and mammals vary
according to the time of day so fun but
slightly irrelevant fact for this video
chrono comes from Kronos which comes
from Greek mythology but there's two
other terms that you need to understand
before we get further into this video
and so that is pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics so pharmacokinetics is
effectively what the body
to a drug where as pharmacodynamics is
what the drug does to a body and say BAE
for these processes are affected by
desiccating rhythm and so this video
will look at why one is so important for
medicine and the simple answer is simply
chi folds the idea behind chrony therapy
is to increase the efficacy of a drug
but also to reduce the side effects that
can also come with therapist so you may
be wondering why so much of biology is
regulated by a 24-hour cycle and I mean
wherever it's 24 hours or if we evolved
in a different planet the central
purpose of having regulation in four
different biological processes is simply
to coordinate processes
that's a compatibles that they happen at
the same time and to separate
incompatible processes so very bad
example that I thought of is let's say
someone's dropping litter on the floor
and someone's got to pick it up
incompatible why doesn't just one person
so it's less efficient
I realize that isn't a very good example
but I've been at math too late but the
biological example would be an enzyme
that creates a substance and an enzyme
that destroys that same substance being
there at the same time that would be an
incompatible and inefficient entity
anyway back to these T times N and let's
look at pharmacokinetics first what the
body does to a drug say there's four key
terms that are associated with
pharmacokinetics absorption distribution
metabolism and excretion of a drug and
so these properties are all really
important for understanding the
pharmacokinetics of a drug and lo and
behold they are also skating
occasionally regulated and so these
different properties are affected by a
variety of different processes such as
feeding cycles your activity levels the
blood flow rates gastric emptying relief
effort but what we look at is the
circadian regulation of expression
levels of metabolic enzymes so these are
the enzymes that might get rid of the
drug they might affect the drug with
certain way
that then activates the drug and a big
family of these enzymes are the
cytochrome p450 enzymes and say they as
I said they're involved in drug
metabolism and they are also known to be
it's occasionally regulated so depending
on when the drug is taken the drug
metabolism may ferry
so the second concept is
pharmacodynamics what the drug does to
the body so the key question with
pharmacodynamics then is what is the
activity of the drug target and so due
to the circadian regulation we know that
the activity levels of certain enzymes
vary throughout the day so in a
hypothetical situation let's say that at
day time this activity level was low and
so if a drug was targeting that targets
about for anything the enzyme it would
be maybe a bad time to take it in the
morning because the drug target isn't
present I say maybe because it also
depends on the pharmacokinetics of the
drug and so it might not be metabolized
correctly in the same time that the drug
target is present and so it's actually
quite complicated to you know make
predictions about different drugs even
if you need the expression levels of the
drug target but one good example that we
do have is that it seems to be better to
take statins at night time and so this
isn't the case for all statins there are
different variations of them but statins
are to lower cholesterol levels and many
studies are showing that nighttime is
the best time to take it it's more
effective and has less side effects and
so given that 80 percentage of targets
say circadian expression there's a lot
of potential use for say codes clocking
the drug I'm so be really interesting to
see how this information can further
enhance the correct timings of drugs so
to aid this research it'd be really good
to train and identify certain classes of
drugs where it could be more effective
to use cryotherapy and say one property
of a drug in particular that would be
important is the half-life of the drug
so not all drugs are the same
some drugs there half-life is very short
and could be pretty much gone from the
body within an hour of the drugs they
can be present for 24 hours and say the
short of the half-life of the drug it's
more likely in theory that timing the
taking of that drug is more important
because it's around for a shorter period
of time and say anything less than 15
hours could potentially have a correct
time or a better time to take that drug
so well we act with current research
then how often is chrono therapy
actually used well one area of study
where it is feeling like it's going to
be very effective is cancer therapy and
so actually quite old study well I say
old because wow I was quite young when
the study came out is metastatic
colorectal cancer where patients who
receive Crona therapy has less side
effects and say OC chemotherapy is a
pretty horrific in terms of side effects
see any way of trying to reduce the
amount of side effects is pretty
phenomenal and so it's really exciting
why that research could take us in the
future but besides clocking the drug you
can also drag at the clock and target
the components of the circadian clock
itself and say in a previous video I
talked about the core clock components
and there are four main proteins that
are involved which I won't go into
detail now just just know that they
exist
and they also regulates expression of
other proteins such as rev up and say or
ever be a master teacher sets and
there's a 20-18 study that reactivated
this protein and so this protein is
involved in the circadian clock
biochemical mechanism of the regulation
of the 24-hour period and by reactor
facing it in mice of glioblastoma they
actually improved the survival rate and
given that the circadian clock is often
disrupted in cancer there's a lot of
potential that reactivating the clock
components itself drugging the clock
could be a really effective mechanism
for cancer therapy so I said that will
quite fast so apologies but besides
concert there's also great advances
being made in treating inflammatory and
metabolic diseases and also there
advances being made in neuroscience as
well and indeed there is a 24-hour
regulation of the permeability of the
blood-brain barrier which is important
for drug getting drugs to the brain and
also the astrocytes that are in the
brain also chew activity levels that
fluctuate throughout the day so what
research is needed to further understand
the efficacy of Crona therapy well it
all comes down to being able to identify
the right targets and the correct
diseases that would actually benefit
from chrono therapy so to be able to
identify the right targets what we would
really need is genome-wide and tissue
wide maps that show you which different
genes are expressed with a circadian
rhythm and obviously the thing is gene
expression doesn't just dictate if that
protein levels gonna fluctuate so you
also need the proteome measurements at
different times of the day and even just
having the presence of the protein
doesn't necessarily mean it's active
because proteins themselves can get
modified and that can fluctuate
throughout the day and then the stem at
a lame how different substances in the
cells as well favor every day I say yeah
this is very complicated and is by no
means a simple task to undertake and
besides that there are other issues such
as how does it change by sex by age how
does it vary depending on a disease
since these days we study normal cicada
rhythm is that the same as somebody has
a disease or save me studies have been
done in Mouse and rats and they're
nocturnal with diurnal species and you
know what about sleeping exercises how
does that affect Crona therapy and so
I'm going back to age we know that the
circadian rhythm dampens as we age so
you know would that make crooner therapy
less effective or could it be more
effective um I'm secondly um looking at
specific studies in mice and rats where
they increase the life span three color
restriction they see an increased
expression of enzymes in the liver that
are involved in drug metabolism so how
could we harness that potential as well
for treatments so there is evidently a
lot of exciting research
yet to come and so going back to my
title the fourth dimension what do I
mean by that well we have the right
targets the right days the right
patients and importantly we need from
all this evidence that the right time
will also be important so hopefully in
this video try to convince you why
chrono therapy has a lot of potential
because it can increase the efficacy and
also try to decrease the side effects
that are associated with taking a
variety of drugs and so this could save
money and also just will generally to be
beneficial and so obviously time will
tell
winky face I stole that pun but you know
time will tell if any of this will end
up being seen and different treatment
therapies but I think has got a lot of
potential and I'm pretty excited to see
what we will uncover in the coming years
so as always thanks for listening